love the new song it's called cancelled
let's start off with bryce hall yeah he
got some smelly
i only know his name cause i just didn't
give him fame now moving on the sister i
think i'm about to diss her that i'm
looking thicker before her getting
bigger
what was the exact moment
uh that really inspired this i mean did
something happen
the exact moment that um started cancer
that made me want to start cancelled was
i watch my friends youtube videos all
the time they're always just going back
and forth
no one ever inquires me in anything like
i'm never in drama because i'm just
friends with everybody but like
also it gets boring when you're just
quarantining and you have nothing to do
besides watch everyone get in drama so i
like
insert myself in it just a little bit
but in a
in a comedic way i didn't want to like
actually start drama because i'm also
like sensitive as hell and i feel like
people could hurt my colleagues easily i
just did it just for funsies and that's
what happened
the keto wanna be the same shade as
lupita tony locke
i mean you do poke fun at a lot of
influencers who are also your friends
bryce hall uh nikita james charles
how did you get them to agree to be in
the video
james it was the easiest thing he
literally wouldn't put you a part of
anything that i'm doing and i feel like
all of them know it wasn't out of like
ill intentions like it wasn't out of bad
intentions at all
it was mainly just for fun takes
everything so seriously so they'll see
like
bryce hall like talking about somebody
and he can be completely joking
but just because the internet just loves
to start drama and just
create negativity after negative
negativity out of absolutely nothing
everyone just thinks you're always
beeping but i just literally show the
internet that i can talk
about people and i can still be in the
same room with them and i can still be
friends with them
because of joke like it's all just jokes
and fun that everything has been taken
seriously all the time
do you feel like people in general take
the tick tock drama
way too seriously oh absolutely i feel
like people care way too much
i feel like people care so much about
what this
tick tocker is doing rather than like
their own lives and i'm like
that's cool but like you have to realize
that you're living through other people
and you're just living watching people
go live your own life like
you know instead of being so obsessed
with someone like if they're dating this
person like
go find you a boyfriend or like go
outside and have fun
there's also lyrics about the
controversy with jeffree star
shane dawson jeffy star says
dawson got
[Music]
have you heard from any of them about
the song
thank god now that was my biggest fear
it was just
getting a season this by jeffree star i
thought jeffy star was going to
literally end my entire career
that was my absolute biggest fear but um
he wouldn't do that would he
no i don't think he would i was just
afraid because i know he's a powerful
person and i know he
has the powers to just take down my
video or something but
i honestly was just doing it out of fun
there is a lyric
that says hi pals freaks they smell like
feet yes thank you
is that true
i've been in the hype house so okay so
you've been saying about cracks
how did it smell to you i mean there was
the kitchen was special okay
so
okay let me clarify there are some rooms
that stink and there's some rooms that
you know they smell like normal rooms um
but yeah that's what's
what's the smelliest room i would say
ryland's room oh he would he would
probably cop to that right
i mean did anyone seemingly at all get
upset
there was not many people upset with my
son all my friends really do like it and
did love it
so the only who were upset was
i don't know like my mom she was like
why are you being mean to these people
and i was like i'm sorry it wasn't
your mom's upset my mom was upset she
was like
why are you talking about white cause
some of her favorite youtubers were in
it and she's like why are you talking
about them like that
but other than that yeah we talked about
how you have no beef with anybody
you're friends with everyone bryce hall
and thomas sway hype
is there is that beef real is it beyond
repair
i wish i cared enough to know but i
really don't so i don't know if it's
good or not
um i hope it's not because there's just
so many other
things we can be worried about like
hey there's more problems to the world
than your young drama but
i don't think it's real i don't know if
it's real couldn't tell you
i have an idea for you yes i think
on your youtube channel you should
mediate
like a therapy session between bryce and
thomas
okay if when i start caring more i will
do that
when i when i care about other people's
lives like that i will most definitely
take that advice that's a good video
and e.t can be there oh i thought we
would slay that me and you
personally if we have we should do that
don't you think we should do that the
red table talk moment
and we can just bring peace and unity
amongst the houses should we do this
i think we just came up with a new
segment and it's gonna have to happen
soon
i love it i think a talk show with you
would actually be really fun
absolutely i'm literally thinking about
it
[Applause]
i do want to know your thoughts because
i am a little bit invested
in radisson and i know a lot of people
are invested in bratison
and as friends of both of them what do
you think of them
doing joker and harley queen on on
halloween and are they back together now
um i think they're really cute
and i will say
out of all the couples they really have
me invested too
even though both of them are my best
friends i'm very invested and i
think they're really cute together
you